herr meyer wer ist dass wer ist dieser
corona mob was wissen sie über diese
menschen
ja erstmal ist natürlich das sehr stark
zu kritisieren dass sich jetzt in diesen
zeiten dort über 1000 menschen
versammelt haben das ist rechtswidrig es
gibt zwar eine möglichkeit zu
demonstrieren im begrenzten rahmen 35
teilnehmer mit abstand und so weiter und
sofort wissen die menschen auch wer dort
aufgetreten ist auch aggressiv
aufgetreten ist das ist eine mischung
würde ich mal sagen nach unserem
kenntnisstand sind dass
rechtsextremisten gerade auch in greiz
unter anderem auch aus dem nachbarland
sachsen rübergekommen aber auch eigene
es sind querdenker darunter
radikalisierte impfgegner also das ist
so eine mischung die es halt sehr
kritisch zu beurteilen ist es eigentlich
wer sind eigentlich querdenker was
verstehen sie als innenminister darunter
naja das ist jetzt ein überbegriff
darunter sind verschiedene gruppen die
sich dann unter dieser bewegung
gesammelt haben anfangs waren es
tatsächlich menschen die sorgen hatten
um solch mal den eigenen betrieb und so
weiter und so fort völlig legitim aber
diese bewegung hat sich ganz klar
radikalisiert wir wissen auch die
zusammenarbeit zum beispiel mit reichs
bürgern ist sehr eng da gab es treffen
nun führungsleuten die sich da
miteinander
strategisch ausgetauscht haben und so
weiter und so fort das sind die
impfgegner darunter also es ist eine in
anführungszeichen bunte mischung die
aber aus unserer sicht sehr sehr
gefährliches hier sind in diesem fall in
greiz sind flaschen geflogen auf
polizisten hier wurde geprügelt eben
hier ist pyrotechnik zum einsatz
gekommen fackeln wieder die wir sehen um
das ganze noch massiver wirken zu lassen
das war eben kurz vorher auch in sachsen
gesehen haben das sehen wir in vielen
teilen deutschlands aktuell nordrhein
westfalens innenminister herbert reul
bei uns kommen diese menschen nach ihren
beobachtungen aus der mitte der
gesellschaft
sie kommen aus mehreren teilen der
gesellschaft wir haben der kollege hat
das ja gerade richtig beschrieben es
waren am anfang sehr viele besorgte
menschen es waren leute die
grundsätzlich gegen impfen es gab leute
die aus der esoterischen bewegung kommen
und immer mehr ist das übergeschwappt in
den rechtsextremistischen bereich wir
können heute feststellen dass
rechtsextremisten diese bewegung diese
unruhe diesen ärger von menschen
missbrauchen für ihre zwecke umgekehrt
muss man sagen diese menschen lassen
sich überhaupt missbrauchen und deswegen
muss das klar benannt werden das kann so
nicht weitergehen das darf sie es nicht
weiter eskalieren wir merken dass immer
mehr von denen die da unterwegs sind
sich gar nicht mehr mit dem impfen
beschäftigen sondern mehr
demokratiefeindliche töne sind
verfassungswidrige könne dabei sind
sprache auf tauscht die die viel zu tun
hat mit dem was auch am burgwall in dem
rechtsextremen bereich auftaucht also
das macht mir große sorgen weil er sich
immer weiterentwickelt und manchmal habe
ich den eindruck egal was der anders ist
sie gehen zusammen auf die straße um
ihrem missmut gegen den staat zu
artikulieren ja und deshalb zunehmend
auch gewalttätig frau
leutheuser-schnarrenberger macht ihnen
das angst was da gerade irgendwie brote
diese komische menge die gerade herr
rühl und meier versucht haben zu
beschreiben zu identifizieren macht
ihnen das angst diese auch zunehmende
gewaltbereitschaft
also es zeigt auf alle fälle das doch
immer mehr bürgerinnen und bürger sagen
sie wollen dass ich nicht gefallen
lassen was ihr regierungen bund und
länder ebene entscheiden sie wenden sich
wie eben her richtig sagte gegen den
staat da haben sie eine einheit obwohl
wir alle der staat sind wo sie ihre wut
ablassen können und ich glaube was uns
sehr beschäftigen und auch besorgt
machen lassen muss ist dass es ebenso
unterschiedliche motivationen gibt die
aber auch in den radikalen bis
extremistischen bereich hinein gehen
aber ist ja nicht eine organisation ist
die man leichter auch von den
verfassungsschutzbehörden überwachen
könnte sondern die setzt sich zusammen
aus vielen bürgern und ich sage ganz
klar jeder der da hingeht und mitmacht
und sieht da entwickelt sich eine demo
manche sind erlaubt aber nicht in diesem
ausmaß manchem versammlung waren auch
illegal und sie sehen dass da solche
parolen gebrüllt werden der macht sich
mitschuldig der muster weg sein nicht
sagen ich will meine meinung sagen und
unterstütze damit läuft und welches
extreme denn auch da sind verschiedene
gruppierungen da die das für sich nutzen